This is not good enough
Okay t-series is taking over India is taking over the European Union approved the banning of millions
article 13 this meant for
Germany it's the Germans again, huh? I didn't want to make any kind of jokes like that
But this time they're back. I try to warn you guys first. They take our freedom then they take our meat
No, wait, whatever. You understand what you understand the stakes. I've had enough
Okay, that's the face you make when you troll the enemy, that's the face of pure evil right there. That's the top boss
I'm sorry, you have to tongue out like that
So, you know, it's so business what we need here is a country not affiliated with European
We need another country to mean what have we got Russia of course, yeah, you like that
Okay, let's go a normal day in Russia dealing with a parking spot dispute. I've seen this
I've never shared my show
Just saw that voting I mean that car
Nobody's saved what I like I was talking like it's
Taking matters in your own hand, you don't go and ban memes or anything like that
I like it a plus for the safety glasses when the guy behind you keeps hitting the chair. I
Love this so much at that moment Victor knew he had messed up big time
What happened to Victor? He tricked so random and like why? Is he on a bus Russia is so random guys
They just went on buses may imagine like a bot. You wouldn't see Obama or Trump or whatever on a bus like this
What's the content what happened to Victor?
Look at his friend is looking at like damn you did not just do that, Victor
You messed up big time boy. Even here. Take a seat
Hey
Perfect. Just realise when I was in Japan. We wrote a the subway a lie, and people kept falling asleep
It happened a couple times people would fall asleep on my shoulder and I was like, ah, that's cute
Now I realized they were just trying to get rid of me dad
Life hack, that's pretty good. See we have a lot that we can learn from Russia. Their way of dealing with problems is
A plus I gotta say very nice
When you have a car crash just entertain yourself build some snowmen, although if they were truly a progressive country
They would build snow when I guess some could you still have a way to go?
Mm-hmm. This can't be real. Why are there so many putin memes like what is he doing?
Hey, look, she's rockin the latest Gucci fashion. Look at her. Why is he always everywhere? How can you be so me mobile?
I understand that they just split the pictures around. Okay, I understand
This is Putin just normally licking his lollipop as you do and then he decided nicely to give it to the kid
Some jerk try to just switch them around but then you have the face of the kid and it's like what the heck? Oh
Look at that kids face is incredible. I really want to know what he see what did potent tell that child to make himself
I need a SOT moving on that face when Putin off for some tea
Why won't you have his tea pour potent no one wants his tea have some tea. No. Thanks
I wasn't asking his residue probably poisoned the tea, that could be it
They probably knew man like Putin always poisons the tea drink tea you guys
Opposition activists arrested while reporting live about arrests of
Opposition activists say they got a great sense of humor. That's hilarious
Look at the guy. He looks so sad. Oh, no
This is definitely not funny. But also very funny my favorite kind of humor
You're like you have you have something very upsetting, but you can still laugh at it
You have something upset upsetting and wrong with the world, but it still makes you chuckle and you move about with your day
That's the kind of jokes. I prefer analog ATM in Russia. See they got great banks. Look at that dude. He looks wonderful
Hey what some money no problem. Just give me your credit card number back in front. Okay, here you go
Here's a fiver on Russian television. They photoshopped the smile of King Yong Ying. That is it
Oh, well, okay
So this is the first picture and I see actual picture
They use one of those face fill tanks, you know where they give anyone a smile the phase app or whatever
- Putin everywhere now. This is kind of freaking me out Russian watch done
Whoa
What
What is happening, why is it normal to have a Barris pet in Russia and Blanc is really in Russian?
Well, it looks like I'm not going to Russia then a normal day in president's life there
There you go again. What does he do all day? He broke his arm
He's too bad old Putin memes. I swear to god he's writing a suicide note for him
Because he can't write with his left hand so thoughtful of him. So that is so
Wholesome guys smash like on this video. That is so nice
Last famine sandy wait, there's women in russia
Less than how well, oh my god
All right
Summary in Russia
Why is everyone in Russia wearing the latest Gucci collection, I don't understand how can they afford it?
All right. Don't make me feel for people too much. Let's move on
So stupid why don't we laugh at these Russian TV everybody?
well, at least I don't have any ads take a Hollywood in Russia who says Russia is not high-class like the
California leaves look at that. I can't tell the difference. Don't you take my parking spot? Ok?
8:35
9:30
You could have just moved the bike. Why move the bike when you can throw it up a tree yay
All right note to self don't ever make a wrong parking in Russia. Got it. Ok
What's the name of this country what I've seen this?
My favorite it's the guy on the lower left who's
Only angry and wants to fight the guy crew in the hill then his buddy comes like no kidding. They're fine
Come on to you there. Okay, let's keep hanging out in the container kiddo
We're having a good time Kira come on, we're doing the slug dance. Is that a real wedding photo?
This is some indian level photoshop, man. Damn
She looks so happy about the marriage has anyone ever smile in a photo in Russia?
You just got to get the phase that that's how the only way whenever there's in a smiling in Russian photos, you know
They use Photoshop Stadium in Russia. Didn't need to be fun : vacation for the World Cup. So they added
18,000 seats in the most terrifying way possible. Do you see anything from this seat Oh what you dude you do? Okay. Well
Belarus ever anyone Russia will arrest your trash
Recycling. It's a subversive capitalist plot. If you pee we'll put you on YouTube
Wait some Russians actually fear this before you're allowed in the tank. You have to prove you're blind trust in it. No
No
whoa, just imagine the cannon just firing the the candidates they
Finish them off. They mastered the fashion game. No one can deny it. Well, that's enough Fiat for me for today
Check out the merch guys. Just kidding. You can't we sold out
Keep subscribing. We need to destroy India
And that's it for me for now leave like and enjoyed this video and I'll see you guys tomorrow
Get out and now a word from our sponsor if anyone
Comments negatively about my camera setup. You will 100% be banned
Yeah, it's time for me to flex on your kids. Very nice. I have the honor play and the new honor of 10
Very nice
Thank you honor for sponsoring this video I of course already have the old one and look at this by the way music my queen
my king
Very nice, but it's time for me to utter brain because now I have the honor play everybody. Let's start by unboxing the honor play
Unboxing time smash like if you like unboxing
Well, I guess here it is already. We didn't even have to unbox it
How about that now what's special about the other play is new? Well many things but it's optimized for
Gaming so it's got GPU turbo which basically means improved graphics performance
increasing efficiency with 60%
Damn, Daniel, basically while you're playing video games. You'll get a stable performance. No lag
No BS it also has an amazing battery on my old one is already amazing
Like I feel like I rarely even have to charge it
So if they've improved on that even more that that's not bad son
You can apparently stream 15 hours of video on this you can watch 15 hours of PewDiePie on this
Ok, if that's not epic. I don't know. What is
95 hours of music
You can even watch if you use the ultra power saving mode by honors power saving technology
A full season of Rick and Morty or your favorite TV show doesn't have to be written Maury
I just assumed it was written morning in one charge. I forgot to mention that otherwise it wouldn't be that impressive
So the graphics processing quality is higher frame rate lower jitter
So you'll be able to play games like pub G they have 3d surround sound and smart shock
so if you get shot anywhere the phone will vibrate in their direction of their bullets and you'll be able to
Distinctively that's a tough word for me apparently
Be able to hear where the shots are coming from
Which obviously if you're playing a game like pub G or any competitive game on your phone?
That's a must so you'll have a major advantage with a phone like the honor play
So I haven't tried out the camera, but it's supposed to have AI technology
Recognizes 500 more and more scenarios since the settings based on it. Damn. I look good
Damn, I look good. It also has a are lens. Oh
Yeah
This changes everything
How I eat it, oh man has a lot of them hey guys, I'm just in London I
Also have to show you my honor 10. Damn
Can you see their reflections? It's not lit enough. Damn it. It's super cool. It looks amazing. I love the look of this phone
So this one is very similar to the honor play very eye-catching
Very nice and looking so this one has GPU turbo as well now to show you
The power of Flex tape and the power of the honor. We're gonna do a dent benchmark test, okay
This is that big so let's let's cut to that
Okay, here's a benchmark test between honor play one plus six and Samsung S nine
plus, these are the settings that we used and we write a MOBA game on it and as you can see
Honored place stays at 60 frames per second steady while on one plus six and Samsung against nine
Is going all over the place, which means you will get
Starting and lag while playing a game which you especially don't want
So here you can see the result 100% stability and honor plays version 90% in 1 plus
85 on the sensor. Okay. So on a plane obviously the best choice everybody